are you ready
[Applause]
plugging classic stores to slamming wind
turbines branding portable rat-infested
pets I will never ever let you down that
I can judge Donald Trump is pressing
some serious pressure points in America
but is it carefully crafted strategy or
just spontaneous sparring political
genius or seriously politically damaged
it really feeds into what the president
really represents to a lot of people
which is he tells it like it is and
no-nonsense kind of guy it's the
greatest slogan in the history of
politics in America great again we still
hear people at these rallies say I love
this guy because he says out loud what
I'm thinking he's okay how's it like it
is he does keep doing a good job well as
those good as anybody else has done to
cutthroat business I guess you know if
they want to do all on that there's
other problems that we need to address
[Music]
[Applause]
if it's a Facebook ad it's a TV ad if
it's a conversation with their neighbor
we know exactly how to engage the voter
based off the data that's the success
that helped us win in 2016 and now the
Danner's pressure and stronger for 2020
but when it comes to those heavy issues
like race get it backfire with moderate
voters 2016 the media called the
president racist
they called him racist and 2017 and 2018
they're doing it again in 2019 it is a
false charge it's inaccurate it's
defamatory he's trying to put those
folks in a box
and I think that he's probably gonna
successfully do that he's trying to
expand that 40 percent by bringing down
his opponents he got Pocahontas is
rising
is it a calculated risk do I agree with
it no but is he trying to do it yes
[Music]
feels a lot like it's on fire and the
Democrats have drowned
just about everyone into the ring to try
and beat this man convinced that the
country wants change what about that
enigmatic elusive old character not him
of course I'm talking about the silent
vote
I've had people actually come up to me
and say and they start up a conversation
like it's oh yeah it's another one of us
because everyone's kind of in hiding
people don't come out they don't want to
come out and say they support Trump
because you get a lot of flack from your
friends you do you get blood so I think
that for the most part people like me if
my mind's made up and people who like
him have their minds made up and I don't
think anybody's changing a lot of
anybody else's money whether you love me
or hate me you gotta vote for me
you